[Music]
what do you have two beards
that's another [ __ ] business I
traveled all the way across the country
to rob a goddamn charity
what associate [ __ ] steaks mom you still
hit like your [ __ ] father not working
with that poison [ __ ] come on boy be
just like old times
you made a living [ __ ] nightmare why
didn't you say so I'm in come on in
fellas
I'll bet that [ __ ] got lips like our
anything excuse me
what's up you got smaller [ __ ] you we're
a charity when you walk out those doors
you're representing us there are some
change think about somebody besides your
[ __ ] self well bless your heart cheap
little [ __ ] you reek of whiskey you
know the rules and you're clouding them
flouting I never sucked jizz out of
nobodies i ass believe that spell Jamie
I'm a good girl but sometimes I need to
be bad tell me how 30 this is it's a
dumpster alley it's pretty [ __ ] dirty
I guess okay it's [ __ ] dirty I am
going to have to ask you to watch your
language when you're representing the
city I'm going to have to ask you to
suck my [ __ ] dick one time I ate too
much turkey bacon I didn't poop for two
weeks for four weeks
is this your spawn do I look like I made
him well if this ain't fetal alcohol
syndrome then what the book is beneath
this time why are you even out of the
joint anyway you know they used to
sterilize guys like you keep the world
from becoming some Negro Land of Oz
early release you racism